un arrière athlètes des cheveux de fou
il a baissé un peu dans les modes draft
il était très coté est ce que ça peut en
faire un potentiel style on parle dans
ce podcast de jay-z davidson le meneur
arrière de l'université d'alabama 30
minutes pour le connaître comprendre son
jeu et ses enjeux ses parties
[Musique]
nos trois coiffeurs du jour pour parler
de jay-z davison
ugb et manu salut oh la la cote de tous
alors en un mot en un mot est ce que
voulaient les mais plus que la moyenne
j'ai dit davidson ou pas oui ou non non
non non et
non plus que la moyenne mais bon il aime
tout le monde puisque la moyenne aussi
c'est celle c'est que la moyenne baisse
du coût
7 mai au dessus
allons-y pour donc son portrait de draft
et est donc le portrait commence tout
simplement par la carte d'identité
qui est il devient t-il ben 7 cet homme
jamie davidson et vient de l'étau hachey
en alabama et un petit bled d'environ
1000 personnes il est né le 3 octobre
2002 donc il il va le 19 ans il va avoir
un
très jeune la prochaine saison nba c'est
d'autres prospects qui est quand même
relativement jeunes ont aujourd'hui
retrouvé d'infos sur sa mère mais pas
sur son père sur internet mais il ya des
photos avec les deux lorsqu'il a déclaré
à alabama à moins que ce soit le copain
de sa mère ou quoi que ce soit
djedid harrison est le plus jeune si
vous entendez mon chien boit de l'eau
non ok
j'ai dit d'aller sonner le plus jeune
d'une famille de quatre frères et comme
les quatre frères ont un nom qui
commence par la même lettre il ya jérôme
80 ans et a dû remarquer ce qui a 25 ans
et il ya mon préféré jack khimki à 20,3
jeddi n'avait sonne quelque chose qui me
qui me gène cretz qui dans son parcours
c'est que il devait demeurer avec son
école secondaire son high school pendant
tout son parcours
vas-y city et il a eu tout pour parce
qu'il a été recruté il était recruté par
au cuir l'académie est pas en reste et
il a dit non et ça pour moi c'est un red
flag qui papa est dû à des circonstances
familiales mais c'est un red flag quand
même qui est pas priorisées son propre
développement sur le succès de son
équipe sur son propre succès aussi donc
ça c'est ce soir que c'est très jeune
dans son développement mais il ya des
questions à se poser le rsa il ya gagné
le championnat vice city 2 a avec son
équipe de alabama de carole calhoun high
school où est-ce qu'ils m'aiment pas il
a fait 3 points par match mais la pêche
bien jeunes croît entre 4 ou 5 passes
décisives par match au total sur la
saison donc là on voit déjà la queue si
peluche un profil de scoreur que de deux
postes un traditionnel comme blogueur il
plus qu'un professionnel et il est signé
avec alabama aux officiers parce qu'il
voulait demeurer près de la maison ceux
qui connaissent le podcast depuis
longtemps savent que c'est un détail qui
mastic particulièrement je suis toujours
un peu douteuse des joueurs qui de la
maison
très bien donc cette asticote tu as tu a
omis de dire quand même que jay-z ses
passes ont évidemment son prénom oh oui
oh mon dieu oui c'est ça c'est la plus
beau d'histoire lui ai dit c'est pas
john david sais pas j'ai démétrius c'est
gerrard
et
c'est gérard dhien en france et donc de
propriété de gérard donc c'est
probablement l'un des noms les plus
prestigieux john darwin
tu attends un peu je dis si jordan ben
oui j'ai mal
john
c
l'appli
gerrard yann c'est beaucoup mieux
bon gérard diane il ressemble à quoi
physiquement hughes évidemment on va
parler de ses cheveux entre où ils
ressemblent aux dealers en bas de chez
moi que je ne côtoie pas d'accord c'est
la sécurité passe dans la poire je n'ai
aucun rapport avec ce mec là
donc oui j'ai dit davison c'est une
coupe de cheveux incroyable de cheveux
qu'il a dû couper après son premier
match parce qu'ils ne voyaient pas ses
propres dires ses propres passer le
pourcentage
extérieur et du coup lui a demandé de
raccourcir ses cheveux pour les besoins
de l'équipe skil a un peu fait mais très
peu sinon c'est un mètre 91 il fait 90
kg il a une envergure à ces deux petites
1 m 93 à 95 donc c'est pas c'est pas un
mec tentaculaires comme on peut les
avoir maintenant assez couramment par
contre c'est un mec qui monté sur
ressorts ils montrent très très haut une
détente sèche formidable qui lui permet
de contrer des pivots il a un second son
incroyable premiers pas assez explosif
assez intéressant il est rapide sans
être top tiers vitesse comme un diable
box par exemple qui était une référence
dans la vitesse au niveau du contact il
y va je trouve qu'il est pour l'instant
pas hyper à l'aise avec le fait de
rentrer dans un des défenseurs ou en
attaque sur son propre corps n'est pas
encore hyper à l'aise là dessus mais
comme il aime bien aller au spectacle
c'est quelque chose qui peut encore
passer à muscler à maîtriser à l'image
du basket du joueur man u man u man u
pourquoi
drafter est on jay-z davidson pourquoi
est il un prospect pour moi c'est
surtout pour son pour son thirith les
pourcentages sont pas dingue pour
l'instant mais quand il prend feu par
qui est assez impressionnant ce qu'ils
foutent beaucoup à trois points
je retrouve sa
non il shoote pas tant que ça il est à
cinq tentatives sur 100 possessions
c'est pas 30 mois la hausse est plus à
utiliser ces fonds plus de 30% de ses
tirs ça à trois points mais c'est ça ça
rende pas des masses des masses mais moi
j'achète le shoot g sur les matchs que
j'ai que j'ai vu c'est quand il marque
il peut prendre feu et il à eelv et 1ère
étape c'est surtout ça que j'achète et
j'aime bien aussi son son ça passe fin
sa vision sont ils capables de passer
même s'il fait pas beaucoup de passes
décisives dans les stats s'il perd aussi
beaucoup de ballons mais j'aime bien sa
capacité à notamment sur on y trouve
beaucoup de a loupé ça j'aime bien je
trouve prince trouve que ça peut se
développer en un peu mieux et faire
jouer dans l'initiation il fait capable
de faire ça à terme pour moi très bien
donc un joueur intéressant
athlétiquement verticalement qui va un
peu vite et donc manu achète le shoot
alors ma première question est toute
trouvée pour les deux autres est ce que
vous en faites de même puisque
effectivement les pourcentages sont pas
jojo il est à 31% sur
deux tentatives et demi par match
et sur les longues tous laissez moi une
petite seconde sur les longues tout donc
les longs de points il en attendait que
22 avril à 50% donc c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant
et puis enfin aux lancers francs pour
pour être complet cette saison j'ai
passé stack high school peut-être que
vous les avez il est à 70% sur 60
tentative ce qui n'est pas bien pour un
arrière mais pas non plus qu'à ta voix
là alors qu'en dites vous messieurs
personnes à chaque fois encore
la sélection de shoots jedid harrison
n'est pas être un peu à l'image de son
jeu en général c'est à dire qu'il n'aura
pas il a pote
ya pas de cohésion il n'y a pas de
réflexion derrière c'est un peu à la va
comme je te mène c'est simple ça fait
partie son rôle alabama aussi parce que
c'est vraiment le vecteur offensif
numéro 1 de l'équipe donc son boulot à
lui c'est de produire de la tactique de
toutes les façons dont il dompte si
possible
et
ma foi ils essaient de son mieux mais il
manque de lits manque de logique dans sa
manière de fois ces deux
c'est comme ça que on vient à perdre
confiance à son show de la développer dh
il ya des jeux jeux support contre
l'idée qui va devenir un joueur efficace
parce que comme vous l'êtes manu sa
technique ces pourcentages à sur
certains choix sont corrects mais c'est
plus un problème qualitatif quelqu'un
stade je vois à gaza hugues sur le tir
avant de passer aux suites du skill
cette annonce une image rejoint un peu
comme le disait fort le contexte alabama
ça et joue avec des forges l'extérieur
aussi lui sort du banc yaqoud noorzai
tchèque alfons dont manu est absolument
amoureux cette équipe est la mentalité
du coach night odyssée de rapprocher le
plus possible son jeu de haut niveau à
niveau nba donc c'est très binaire c'est
du tir à trois points beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de tirs à trois points et du
tir près du panier ya pas de mi distance
et dans ce domaine la diète et davison
il tourne beaucoup ta date à la ligne à
trois points qu'on a le ballon il ya un
pic à noël il a beaucoup tourné autour
de la ligne à trois points il va pas les
prendre saint jean qui est beaucoup dans
l'hésitation
pour l'instant dans son volume de tiercé
kasic du catch and shoot à trois points
80% de ces tyrans 400 sud et l'est
efficace que lorsque laval elle arrive
sur sa main droite directement donc dès
que le ballon arrive sur sa main gauche
il est pas capable d'en mettre qu'est ce
que j'achète le tir n'ont en tout cas
pas pour l'instant peut-être il serait
plus à l'aise aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mi
distance quand il rentre dans du pick
and roll ce qu'il n'a pas le droit de
faire
du coup du coup quel quel est le rôle
qu'on va lui est assignée en nba puisque
parfois c'est complètement
différent de ce qui se passe au pied et
ça change complètement un joueur est ce
qu'il ya scénario qui est possible avec
j'ai dit davison ou est-ce qu'il est
condamné à être ce mec un peu athlétique
qui sort du banc et qui scorent quoi
pour moi c'est une joie de sorties de
bain
6e 6e 7e homme dans le moule le plus un
joueur qui doit avoir beaucoup de
latitude pour s'exprimer donc mon
commandant de l'attitude de la laine de
la latitude un joueur en billets on lui
on lui envoie un cas est dit dans cette
campagne qui comme comme comparaison ce
qui est pas du tout quand on dit encore
fini qui se croit l'ancien de mary state
bronze jeunesse on sacrifie knicks ont
connaissance d'autres moi est de voir
comment exactement était presque à
l'heure d'aller oui a besoin de de
s'exprimer à une bille a besoin dans
tropic
manu
pourquoi il perd autant de ballons parce
que ça c'est la question quand même qui
vaut qui vaut à ses chers vu que il a
plutôt le gabarit d'1 1 mais que
jusqu'ici on en a pas parlé comme d'un
potentiel monnaie
fait des pages free tente des passes
risquées moi je trouve surtout tentent
beaucoup de l ue que d'effacer un peu
trop haut et du coup son pivot où son
ailier qui débarque n'attend pas la
balle donc sa part on touche et c'est
pas un initiateur de première en fait
ils sont pas forcément beaucoup de jeu
et du coup des fois il tente d parce
qu'ils sont complètement à côté du truc
et ça ça va pas dans le jeu et du thar
de balle portent pour la pour son ailier
son arrière qui perd là battrons tous
fins et c'est pas des passes senti en
fait qui fait je trouve
il fait la passe parce qu'il doit faire
une passe c'est pas il manque un truc je
pense qu'il pourra le faire à terme bien
entouré moi je le vois deuxième
troisième meneur un an et demi mais avec
du travail ça va ça va venir s'il ya
quand même pas mal de flash sur des sur
des belles passes moi je suis plutôt
sereins là-dessus hugues est ce que tu
peux parler de son l'attirail du meneur
c'est à dire le dribble ce qui l'a le
dribble dès demain est-ce qu'il a le
dribble bas dans les petits espaces et
ce qu'il a les passes à une main à
demain à terre par dessus la tête tout
ça allait venir là dessus j'aime
beaucoup son
son dribble initial il est capable de
partir dès demain ils changent de main
par contre il dribble vraiment trop haut
pour le monde ils avaient trop est-ce
qu'il provoque beaucoup de pertes de
ballons ils essaient de protéger sa
balle tu qu avec son sa main qui tient
pas le ballon et beaucoup là-dedans il
essaie de mettre du contact pour se
protéger mes amis jouent contre eux dès
maintenant plus développé qu'en île
school c'est que très compliqué pour lui
mais je trouve qu'il ya un vrai
potentiel sera encore une fois sur
pick'n roll jeu c'est un joueur que
j'aime beaucoup dans ce secteur-là et
qui fait ses meilleures séquences
lorsqu'il arriva à peu à poser le jeu à
prendre imposer un peu le tempo et
arrêter d'être juste une pile électrique
qui fait des allers retours il ya un
vrai potentiel à à développer chez ce
mec parce que comme le dit manu il ya
beaucoup de passes soleil à passer de
faire un flotteur est maman de séance un
voyou et cetera donc y'a de la
versatilité sur ce secteur génère
strathairn à développer gérer là dessus
moi
c'est un truc de c'est un truc de de
cheveux aussi un d'être un meneur un peu
fou fou comme kobe wake était finalement
jeddi davidson pour les fans de regarde
jamais le problème non c'est marrant
bns qui est ce qu'il est en fait ils
impriment de manipulation des défenses
pour moi c'est un passeur à réaction
parce qu'en fait on je demandais
pourquoi il perdait beaucoup de ballons
il a 27 % de balles perdues ce qui est
énorme ir qui quand il est sur le
terrain il perd plus d'un quart des
ballons de son équipe
et dans le même temps
il l'est
à plus de 28 % de passes décisives ce
qui est pas mal ce qui me plutôt bien
pour un freshman n 6 est dans une grosse
conférence est 1 donc pour moi c'est un
passeur à réaction
quelle qu'elle skie lé 7 on peut le voir
développer rapidement jay dee pour pour
maximiser sa capacité physique ce soit
qu'il faut travailler l'explosivité
latéral question notamment de sortir
le premier pas la sortie pick and roll
ces choses là question de gagner sept
secondes l'adav ans qui n'a pas peint
présentement sur les défenses adverses
qui fait en sorte qui est un passeur un
peu plus réactif ça je crois que ça
pourrait aider on dit déjà c'est un
athlète mais c'est pas un athlète plus
plus et justement il se retrouve
vraiment dans une situation avec des
athlètes absolument sanguinaire devant
lui
je crois côté côté pas s'il faut falloir
sponsoring pas une question de
développement est ce qu'il va falloir
lui enlever des responsabilités je crois
pas que je pense que personne d'entre
nous qui croient que c'est important de
ballons primaires
primaires initiateurs je pense qu'on est
d'accord là dessus il va falloir lui et
lui alors je crois que
le syndrome oc aussi son succès story
par un petit peu un syndrome penguins
c'est à dire il va devenir meilleur
qu'on va lui enlever des responsabilités
puis on va affiner son rôle chez que je
parle pour ma paroisse mais 'quand'
games en thuya ndi
est un excellent joueur régulier dès
qu'on l'a arrêté de lui demander de
manier le ballon et d'aller au panier
quintiles est devenu joie des lieux à
stephen king james était un bon shooteur
quand même meilleur que davis anna
semble à son âge non tu disais que tu
sais copie doit être copié voici ce que
le nom de plus en plus d'arrêter de le
projet ça c'est ma paroisse à moi
maintenant mais on arrêtait de faire
très bas normand était de le faire en
tant que meneur il fait que du catch and
shoot et les renversements il ne le fait
pas
est ce que parce que vous me dites tous
c'est pas tel joueur c'est pas tel
joueur et c est ce que c'est un joueur
nba tout court c'est ça va paraître un
peu violent comme question mais vous
râlez avant et du billet
il faut avoir un
il faut vendre quelque chose quoi manu
disait son point fort c'est le tir ce
qu'il est sans doute raison en tout cas
son scoring mais
le fait est que ce n'est pas encore
assuré et que vous l'achetez pas tous il
ya j'ai l'impression qu'à aucun ce qu'il
ce qu'il propre à djezzy davison que
vous achetez donc est ce que c'est un
joueur nba ce qu'il faut le draft tout
concorde pour moi il va être fort faire
des voyages angeli oui oui la g-league
dans son futur je le vois mais oui c'est
exactement le problème alex tu mis le
doigt dessus you potes de cartes de
visite joël draft mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi si je l'admets mais moi
personnellement
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui va
le faire descendre il peut terminer
deuxième tour je pense c'est vrai qu'il
risque pour l'instant il est il un peu
glissé dans les dents l'emop mais avant
avant la saison il était assez haut
comment comment on peut expliquer ça use
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on ne
voit pas
voit pas et qui est masqué par cette
année alabama où finalement il sort du
banc il est derrière des gens qui ont
des gros usagers que je pense qu'il a
fait un très bon alors l ue avec jabba
baissé entre autres
bref il a il a fait un très très bon eh
oui la lumière valeo jerry smith et on
s'est tu vois un athlète de fouillis
monté sur tout le monde sur les robes
offensif et tous les thèmes honneur
principal de l'équipe ils ont fait des
belles perfs il avait été justement très
très bon dans le pick and roll le fait
d'envoyer sur orbite et ses intérieurs
donc si une équipe a des souvenirs de
cet été là je pense que c'est pour
l'image qui pourrait en avoir mais comme
ben et menus moi je fais le tour ou bien
30 au style jazz primo l'an dernier
ouais c'est un jalon format plus cacher
parce que là il lui manque il lui manque
un ou deux en développement si on croit
en le tir et en le cerveau en gros et
ben du disait je sais plus quand tu
disais ça tu disais moi je doive plus
les joueurs sur des six quoi surtout au
premier tour ouais je savoure à quesques
draft je veux savoir qu'est-ce qu'elle
ce que je peux
savoir qu'est ce que je peux prolonger
qu'est ce que je peux sur quoi je peux
battre ces villages et aucune raison
on nous reste il nous reste est ce que
vous avez quelque chose d'autre à
ajouter finalement puisque peut-être
qu'on a fait le tour s'est rapidement on
n'a pas parlé de sa défense
qu'est ce que ma nuque est ce que tu
peux me dire sur sa défense
moi j'achète pas la défense je trouve
assez lent dans tout ce qu'il fait et au
poste il se fait dégommer ses sauts
costaud post-bac en joueurs de l'attak
nos paniers c'est terminé il tient pas
le choc
et là moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à le voir
progresser sur cet aspect là du jeu
parat j'ai très peur que ce soit un gros
gros points forts comme points points
noirs sur sur son jeu et du coup même le
masque et ça va être très très compliqué
il sera ciblé tout simplement
ils provoquent des passages en force si
on doit dire un truc sympa sur sa
défense il se place souvent bien il aime
bien prendre des coups dans sa tête
peut-être qu'ils voient juste pas le mec
qui porte le ballon mais le cas ils
provoquent des passages en force
c'est vrai c'est mal et provoque des
passages en force si on a fini sur jamie
davidson on peut peut-être dire
quelques mots rapides de chacals forte
du coup puisque
de ce que j'en entends c'est peut-être
lui finalement le prospect ou peut-être
que c'est bediako j'en sais rien hot
prospect primat du prix le prix en vaut
le tour est ce que c est ce que c'est
c'est pour toi manu le le prospect
numéro un de cette équipe dallas bahamas
et jayden shackleford je dirais oui mais
parce que j'aime beaucoup coûté ans lui
aussi
j'aime beaucoup ce qui ce qui peut
apporter non c'est un peu enfin queen
orly c'est un peu un coutume c'est un
jour qui étaient attendus très très haut
qu'à transfert de de villanova parce que
ça fonctionnait pas et décrit
shackleford avant
mecha colford est encore plus incroyable
parce qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de shooter
ils arrêtent pâtir filoche pas c'est un
simple pour moi c'est peu guilde en plus
fort parce qu'il est capable d'initier
en plus que pouvait pas faire de guilde
à oklahoma
et ça s'appelait encore meilleur thé
dans chaque iphone c'est quelqu'un qui
tournait un arm pour lui-même le fait de
ne pas avoir d'armes il est prêt
absolument tout l'été et les réussit la
plupart adista il a l'air de de gaulle
delevoye pays a accès difficile
à regarder jouer
je souhaite très fort qu'il arrive à un
billet et qui se tapent genre un match
de haut point final avec neuf tirs à
trois points
attendant il est il est encore un ratio
2 à 6 balles perdues qui est inférieur à
1 bien inférieurs même
ça reste un spécialiste non c'est vrai
ça
c'est le genre de joueur qui peut se
drafté d'autant qu'il est à ses tanks et
je veux dire physiquement physiquement
défensivement il a les armes pour tenir
le choc sur plus d'une position va dire
je vais mettre top 5 de mon bilan mais
ce genre de joueur qui dans une
soirée de sauvegarde l'acier donne le
goût de vivre ta vie d'une manière
efficace et plus belle et plus colorée
c'est beau c'est beau ce que tu dis ben
on appelle la zhejiang moi et moi et
allan qui buvaient de l'alcool en
regardant johnny
johnny du zen qui qui performe toujours
pas l'oublier
nous avons une question de faim comme
d'habitude la petite question bonus sur
ce podcast jedid à wiesen on a beaucoup
parlé de ses cheveux
effectivement donc question capillaires
ou capilotractée selon nous allons
élire le meilleur style des draft et
2021 alors j'ai pris que ce qui était
vraiment sur place parce que sinon
deuxième tour il y avait aussi des
petits style sympa et je parle de la
coiffure draft night hockey de cannes
avec josh qui dit avec son éternelle
brushing comme un sérieux candidat
nous avions john green qui avait qui
avait aplati
freeze et c'était harold c'était ouais
c'était ça partait un peu sur le côté
comme sa
trésorerie très original à zahia jackson
était stylet avec des tresses très très
stylé détresse dont une coloré
et david mitchell avait opté pour les
tresses plaquées très très stylé aussi
alors je vous demande votre vote s'il
vous plaît
m'écouter pour l'ensemble de son oeuvre
incluant le brushing le physique ingrat
et le tard à la basse je trouve que josh
qui dit se démarque comme larry bird de
la génération z donc je vais y aller
avec jalil
physique en gratter un peu durant les
grands minces avec des petits brol comme
notre bon vieux là oui et alors
avec jérôme ans des petits bras
je les trouve adorable je les aime merci
alors manu akiva catherine josh green et
il était pas eu green green je confonds
toujours leader john green c'était
c'était original hugues en bas parce que
chômeurs on voit john mitchell voilà
tout simplement tout simplement l'amour
de belleville viennent on reste fidèles
me suis un vieil michelle et moi je vais
défendre évidemment un hasard jackson
et vivement que mike turner se cassent
des indiana pour que le son talent
puisse exploser aux yeux du monde et
c'est l'essai de cazouls je sais je sais
voila voila c'était sur djezzy davidson
un peu des deux shackleford un peu sur
jean-louis david
voilà c'était un peu de tout ça sur
podcast donc donc on vous donne rendez
vous pour le prochain portrait de draft
et n'oubliez pas les planètes draft sur
youtube n'oubliez pas les des stream
tous les vendredis sur twitch et
n'oubliez pas les articles quotidiens
sur envergure point c'est au vous pouvez
vous abonner vos abonnés à tous à tous
les liens sont disponibles un peu
partout on fait en sorte que ça soit le
plus facile possible pour vous d'accéder
à notre contenu n'hésitez pas à le
partager si vous le trouvez cool et
notre nouveau logo est disponible sur
des t-shirts et des pulls aussi si vous
si vous avez envie de représenter un peu
envergure dans les soirées branchées
bisous à tous et à bientôt